the kind of way i store information in
my head
uh
was
was uh
in harmony with
with with understanding a
computing machine you know i wasn't good
at
like radio i couldn't understand things
like that but i could understand bits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi don nice to see you
okay
yeah i wish i could see you
in person of course yes indeed
um so thank you very much for joining me
it's very nice that you were game to do
a polylogs
session
okay i love it
and how would you so how would you
describe yourself as a computer
scientist even though i would describe
myself as a computer scientist uh
and uh and uh
you might say a lapsed mathematician
because i i began in mathematics but i
switched to computer science
in in the 60s
right yeah but anyway it's i i i
consider that
that mathematics and computer science
are
are distinct but but very related and
the thing that relates them is that they
are the two
sciences that
where we get to make up our own rules
other scientists have to
have to study nature but but we we study
uh
uh
constructions that are
that are
natural or unnatural whichever we like
so would you say that mathematics is the
foundation or a foundation of computer
science
so
um
and vice versa
uh
uh
mathematics was recognized
a few hundred years earlier uh but but i
really think that they're
that they're too
i mean you could argue
that one is a subset of the other uh
either way or but i consider them as
sort of parallel
uh
aspects of of science one is
one is more
concerned with
with infinity
for example than the other than the
other
uh
and and
you know so so for example i
when i was at caltech i had a roommate
office mate for for a while
um and he and i intersected that
countable infinity i never thought of
anything more than carnival infinity he
never thought of anything less than
common infinity
right
nice
um
so you've spent a good part of your
career writing um the art of computer
programming would you consider that sort
of a history of
computer science in a sense
well it's
i i try to do it right i try to get the
history correct uh
but
you know mostly i try to
take the parts of computer science that
i understand and put them on and
organize them and that includes uh that
includes telling the history as well as
the as well as the facts
and in fact uh
as you know as a writer the best way to
uh to get through to somebody else about
facts is to have a story that goes with
it because
we've been
uh
you know
fastening on information through
storytelling for
thousands of years and that and and so
uh
knowing the human element
and
and
how things were discovered is
is
to me uh
equally important to to what is true
but it also helps
well it helps the history helps for many
many ways
one is to understand uh
uh
how
different parts of the subject fit into
each other
but also to understand
that
well
how new discoveries are made and
therefore
by moses i learned how to
develop new ideas tomorrow
because i got to understand how how
other people discovered the ideas that
that are known today
do you define algorithm
so i define
algorithm
as a
as a formal process
that
consists of
of
stick of
steps that
that
they have
something
understood
to be input and something
[Music]
to be understood to be output and then
there's a way to
uh to
look at the input and decide what step
what
what operation you're going to do next
so you go step by step through this
process
and then uh
algorithms that there's only one thing
but the main thing is that that
this is an abstract concept
it's not it's it's not
um
like what's an integer
integer two is an abstract
thing
but but you can write it on a piece of
paper and then you've got
then you've got an embodiment of the
number two or you can have two you know
pieces of pie or something like that
now um
[Music]
the only thing controversial is does an
algorithm have to stop
or not um
or or can it be going all the time and
can does the input have to be presented
uh uh
all at once or or or can the input
becoming coming in after after you've
made some output things like this so for
so if i'm
so zoom is an algorithm that's that's
working
that
that's working uh
on and on i mean actually
there'll be a time when i leave the
meeting and
it will end but but
uh
there are also computational methods
that don't have to end so so there's the
little glitches in the form of deafening
but the main point is that an algorithm
is an abstract idea that doesn't have to
be
ever
written in uh
it doesn't have to actually run on any
particular machine an algorithm is
something that the babylonians had
when they were
doing
figuring out how to
calculate interest or something like
that
but but the
but then there's a program an appro
program is an embodiment of an algorithm
in into into some language
um
so algorithm is an abstract thing the
program is the
it is the uh
exactly the same way information
uh
is abstract and data is it embodiment of
that information
so algorithm works on information and a
program works on data
right
i hadn't thought of it that way before
well that's that's why i
i wanted to say it because i'm pushing
this
right um
and
your book starts um sort of talking a
bit about the history or etymology of
the word algorithm can you oh
that's right page one right
and and that took me back to
ancient persia
and uh
and the word algorithm um is uh
it derives from
uh the name of a great textbook writer
is me i don't
i'm sure i don't pronounce
my name properly uh and
uh but uh
but it's
uh it it it
it's funny because
people didn't you know for a long time
forgot where the word algorithm came
from and that and
and there was people there were reports
about a king al gore of castile and all
kind of strange things and
uh
but but but then when uh when that when
i found out
that it that that was based on
on the
uh uh uh
uh
and that this meant that he that he came
that he was caught he was he was a
christman which is
i learned that that
there was a lake horrorism uh
which is uh now called something else
errol c or something like this i guess
it's called um
and uh
and so i
i
i knew that uh since my life's work was
about algorithms i
i had to go there and so
in in
1978 i guess it was like i was able to
make a pilgrimage not to do cars
wow
that must be quite something
and would you say an algorithm is
essentially a recipe
objections
it's very much like a recipe but it's
more exact than
than what you find in the kitchen uh
it it doesn't it it doesn't say you know
simmer until brown it
just
you know
simmer until the temperature reaches
greater than or equal to
such and such sex and grade or the where
the color is anyway everything
it is defined uh
down to the last detail
while a recipe
is more informal and and and says use
your judgment uh
you know uh
salt to taste or something like this
i guess unless you're baking because it
doesn't work so well with baking i mean
if you want a precise result
so i'm learning how to
navigate in the kitchen
uh but but like
don't ask don't ask my wife how good i'm
doing
um how did you become a computer
scientist what kind of hooked you
all right well uh
so i was a uh
i was majoring
in physics i guess
at
case as an undergraduate
as a freshman and i
um
and
so i started in september and and in
december uh
case got a
strange machine
and i and i had a part-time job
uh
sorting cards
for the statistics
uh and that used an ibm
machine called the card sorter you put
cards in the hopper and
and they get distributed into ten piles
and then you pull them out and put them
through again and you can sort
eventually the cards are in order and
you know i got paid for that
um and so i
supported myself and but in that same
building in the basement they got this
new machine and i
i could see it through the window and i
asked somebody about it oh this is a
computer
um and uh and the lights were flashing
look kind of fascinating and
and so one of the guys explained it to
me
and that's what hooked me because uh
uh well actually it was it was
it was a little bit stranger than that
because i
uh he showed me the manuals for it and
and the manuals were incredibly bad uh
until the manual was here's how you do
this and
and i said but no there's a much better
way obviously you do this
and so uh
and so i figured okay um
i'm only a freshman and and
and and
yeah and i don't
you know
i can run this machine better than the
the guy who wrote the manual there might
maybe i have a talent for it right
so if if i'd started out a machine that
was like today's machines which are all
all fancy and
and refined and so on and all the
manuals are beautifully written and
explained
i probably would have thought oh yeah
well this is pretty interesting but it's
something that's way beyond me
uh
but the fact is at that time it was a
big motivating factor that
uh the manual was stupid
uh and and and but also uh
there's something about me that i was
that i didn't know at the time but i i
but i had been born and geek because
there are some people who
whose brain by the time they get to that
age um
had to
have as a
uh
the kind of way like i store information
in my head
uh
was
was uh
in harmony with uh with with
understanding a
computing machine you know i wasn't good
at
like radio i couldn't understand things
like that but i could understand bits
and so
and so there's something
there was something about the way
the the way my
uh
my head
had
organized itself by that time that that
made me especially
attracted to um
to the machine so i so i spent a lot of
evenings
with the machine and later when i wrote
my book i dedicated it
to the
ibm 650 computer
once installed the case into the
technology in in in memory of many
pleasant evenings
sweet
um
so how do you define
computer science
what is computable okay so i so that's
two different words
um so so what it so people
argue about what is how you define any
field
and
and um
i don't want to
and i don't think the actual precise
definitions are
as long as we know what it is we don't
have to define it but but but like how
do you define mathematics in one
one working definition it's what
mathematicians do
and and so a lot of computer science is
what computer scientists do but that of
course that's in the circular argument
doesn't get you an error but but
in a way um
uh
the the more important is is is to
figure out what it means rather than to
to set up a sharp boundary and say this
is computer science and this isn't or
something like that uh
um so as i said before it's it
it it relates to a
like a kind of knowledge that
that is not part of nature but is but is
uh human-made
um
but what but what is it that
to me it's uh
it's primarily uh uh
this uh the study of of
of algorithms but
computer science also
the the sort of the most accepted
definition of when people were arguing
about it in the 60s when it was new
uh was that it's it's the science of
computers or
in other words the
study of all of the knowledge that
surrounds computers in some way
and so uh that includes processes
what i said but it also includes
building
building circuits that
that that multiply divide
and uh it also includes
various
various things about
vision and
you know processing
audio and video data
etc
um
and
and uh
you know later it's
it
it comes to include things like
security privacy
um
in other words
all kinds of things
the world is developing us it's kind of
like all
all-encompassing and yeah so
so you know up until 10 years ago
computer scientists were saying well
yeah we know all this stuff but nobody
listens to us but now it's gone
completely the other way too many people
are listening to us and believing
you know and realizing
that they don't
realize how little we know
um
and and everything
we've been doing has had turned out to
be affecting
uh
all the other sciences and and the
non-sciences and
and so it's cut
you know
it's gotten much bigger than uh that
than any of us would have
have imagined and and and the same is
true of mathematics that that it becomes
part of
of all aspects of life
some way
here we are
um so
the sort of secondary question to that
was what is computable
right
so
some things are
not
that's a form
this is a
a formal thing where you say something
is not computable that means that there
is no algorithm for it
um
that is uh
uh
nobody will ever be able to figure out a
way to to solve certain
certain
computational problems
and and so like
let's say a number is is is computable
if
if there's a
precise way to
calculate it and stop
but it's not computable if you if if the
only way to known is it would
would take forever
um
so
i mean the most famous uh
thing that's not computable is is is if
you're if i'm given a description of a
computer program can i
can i say
uh
whether it's going to stop
it's called the halting problem
is find some way of
of listing all of the computer
problems in the universe and say what's
the
what's the 1 millionth
program that
that
doesn't stop
how do you tell the story of the history
of the field i mean i guess you're
telling it through sort of case studies
with your book would you say well um
yeah in my book i don't i
i don't go into the
details of people's lives
i mostly i mostly say what's been
published uh uh about the facts that are
true and approximately when they were
when they were done
but i do have a little but but uh
uh
it's actually quite fascinating to go
back into the into the origins of things
so
uh
so you mentioned uh the history of the
word algorithm and that and
and how how course we wrote this that
this book uh
his book his book
told how to uh
how to do
uh how to add numbers together in
who started using that uh
started to put his name into it and
eventually
got got called elegant
uh but but
but
but anyway history
uh
of the field
to me is it is
in the history of the ideas
um
and
and i i'm uh i'm worried that
however that
right now
there are
very few people in the world who are
considered historians of computer
science
um and the reason is that
there are very few
universities or any anything else in the
world
that has a job opening for somebody who
would call himself a historian of
computer science
um and so
just in contrast with the history of
mathematics
where the where they're
where they're still there are uh uh
historians of mathematics uh
uh
you know excellent around the world
well
um
well if you're in america but
then in europe but but anyway um
yeah it's a good tradition in britain
there's a good good tradition of
mathematics in particular right so
right so the british
society for historic history and
mathematics
you know is is excellent and they have
so many good people
um and and then there's also history of
science you know there are people doing
history of physics
history of chemistry
biology and so on and
um
and
so stanford will have
uh have somebody in the history
department who deals with history sign
um
and some and somebody maybe history of
technology or something like that
i started to uh
feel really bad about this when i saw a
paper
made
maybe 10 years ago now
by the man
who was the leading historian of
computer science
and he was a professor at
at the university ward
and
and he wrote a paper
uh
published in the annals of the history
of computing uh called the history of
the history of computer science
and
and and he started out
in his paper he goes through with a
timeline and sort of for every year
starting in 1960 or so he listed
the three most important
that year of about the history of
computer science
and
um
and then he classified them in into
different
different kinds i forget what the
classifications were but but anyway
let's say one of them was
studying of the science
um and the other one another one would
be
study of
of the uh of the funding
okay
so historians have what they call
internal history and external history
and
and also so you look at 1960s and and
they're all category
science
and you look at the last 10 years
none of them
science anymore
all had switched over
and and
and this was computer science i i got
by the time i finished reading his paper
i
i was crying so much i couldn't read
anymore
you know my my glasses had gotten all
covered with tears i'm serious i was
i i was i was desolate by the
the fact that
that there was the leading historian of
computer science saying i'm not going to
teach my students to write the old kind
of history anymore
um and and well uh so so i so i vented
about this and i gave a lecture if you
look on the web you can look up the
kailath lecture and i think i have seen
it it's called let's not dumb down the
history of computer science let's start
dumb down the history of computer
science right
and you said you were essentially
flaming
yes i i i hate i i hate uh
arguing things like i i much prefer you
know presenting beautiful stuff and i
don't like
confrontations and so on uh but
but
and so i figured maybe it's the greatest
mistake i would make uh doing this but i
just had to
uh to had to vent my my frustration and
and and well it turns out that um
that the reader that
that the reason for it uh
also i i i
as i learned more once again about this
question it is very closely led to the
idea that uh
that people who
who work on who who
have as their career uh the history of
of something uh uh have to get paid for
it or else they have to or else they
have to be independently wealthy um
and
uh and and uh
so so martin
the guy i'm talking about
he had been he had been doing the old
kind of computer science history but but
none of his colleagues
could understand what he was talking
about
and
and they didn't want to admit
their
their ignorance and so they
so he couldn't get favorable reviews for
his work
um
talking about the substantive ideas of
computer science
and this has happened not only in
compute it's happening everything except
mathematics and mathematics so far has
been
had been pretty much spared this uh
this trend but i'm but i
you know i i went to the leading journal
of science
jesus uh it had nothing to do with the
terrorist organization but it's
founded by george sarton uh
50s or so and and i looked at uh
you know the articles in uses from 50
years ago compared to now and how many
of them were talking about science and
how scientific ideas were discovered
versus how many of them are dealing with
the kind of pressures that people faced
as they were
trying to
live their life
articles that could be understood by
somebody who doesn't know a damn thing
about i'm sorry a darn thing about
science
so so uh
now
external history is
is is interesting and fine and
and like
you know
people do need to uh
i mean there's lots of questions about
political sources that people have yeah
but
but
i think the right way to do history is
is
is to uh
to have a combination of both depth and
breadth you have
you have a broad picture and then you
zoom in on some of the things and if you
can and if you're a good historian you
should be able to explain the technical
details to somebody who who's not a
a
a
rocket scientist
you can explain the details about rocket
science or whatever science you're
talking about
um
well let's zoom in on some details then
what would you say was the pinnacle of
advancement that you witnessed over the
course of your um career
what surprised you or most impressed you
or
well
so
um
and the question of surprise
you know
the answer is easy everything surprised
me um i i i
i don't think any of my pre
any of the things that i observed
were
i would have predicted
i i started writing my books in 1962 and
and uh uh
every week after that i've been
surprised by something new that's been
that's that's been discovered
um
and hence you're still at it so maybe
but but
but then then you also say what are the
milestones or something like this and
this is this i remember another
it was it was eures hartmannis who was
uh
uh head of cornell computer science
department uh
in the 60s and one of the very you know
founding fathers of our field
and i was a math professor at caltech in
the 60s and he came out to talk to me
and
and
and
he and i had the same
jesus advisor actually turned out and we
both went into computer science later i
was still in mathematics
so he was so so he said to me
let's let's say 1965 four or five
it texts me then he said okay what was
the most important thing that was
discovered in computer science this year
and i couldn't
you know
i couldn't think of anything from that
year you know i i knew things that i
thought were important but
but but
but you know
we were eating dinner and he asked me
this question and i thought hey that's a
good question but i don't i can't think
of anything
um
uh really major you know
um
and uh
but i could think of a lot of things
that i had seen that were rediscoveries
of
good stuff that i had seen before okay
but anyway
so so i uh
kind of every year after after i had
that dinner with with harmonics i
i i sort of
in the quiet moment i asked myself okay
what's the most important thing that
happened in computer science this year
and i never
and i never have an answer for it but
but but after 10 years the whole field
has changed
and and and so i i've come to the
conclusion that the real way to
understand it is
that it's it's not
breakthrough results
that make the field it's it's thousands
and thousands of incremental results
and they they and they and they really
they really mess and that's what's
really important that's what's really
important and that's what
that's why it's taken me so long to
write the art of computer program but
but uh
it's not
like it's not the right model to to
focus on
on
[Music]
big leaps
somehow
in retrospect
we see that there were great leaps of
discovery of
i mean
was there
a dozen important subfields of computer
science each one of them sort of had its
first
its first
week
of existence and and what and and came
out of something but it wasn't
clear at the time that it was going to
be
it was going to be something like that
so
so in my own life
that for example i
i think
a couple of the ideas i had
turned out to have uh
a really good payoff afterwards uh
and some of them have fizzled but maybe
they're gonna have another life
something someday
[Music]
you've got your name on a few algorithms
at least right
yeah having a name though
is
is
it necessarily uh
as significant as
as having people using
uh using the idea
but but it's true that
there's there's somebody's law that
every that everything named is
named after the wrong person inclu
including this life
[Music]
but uh but uh uh
it's
it it's it it surprised me
that my
my name is attached to
some
algebraic constructions in my ph.d
thesis i didn't know about it
hardly anybody works in this
area now and i haven't googled it for
for for 20 years but
there used to be papers written about
the canoes ternary ring
okay i don't remember
myself exactly what it is
right
and then there's one that's essentially
the control f right when you're trying
to find a
string of
um
letters in text
yeah
what about it
what's that algorithm called that's one
of you did
okay so so so there's uh
there's a barrel name
right um
and uh that has a berkeley connection
because jim moore
was there at berkeley and and von pratt
was too
and
when we
when we worked on that um
so uh yeah that was uh
that was where i came in third uh uh the
others had
had we all all three came up with uh
with the same idea in different ways
um
and and and that's a
i guess it's it's become known because
it's gotten into textbooks
although i'm not sure
how many people are actually using it as
we as we speak
but is it essentially the control f if
i'm if i'm trying to find something in
in text
well
it it it's true that uh
that we explained a a a a good way to uh
to find
a sub string of a given
piece of text yeah where do you think
there should be more or less emphasis in
computer science
well um
everybody has their
uh
their their favorite domain of course
and uh
uh and and and this is the importance of
diversity
um
so
uh
my own prescription is it
is is strictly personal
of course and and there are many
different
very very
many different
views of it um
so what i'm
what what i'm seeing now is um
uh
not not as much attention given to
uh uh to things that are useful
in in solving
real problems as opposed to useful for
getting published
uh
there are
i i see beautiful ideas i have
that that i think
are are
are
really great not only because they
you know they
they haven't
they hang together nicely
but also because i can see that
that if i had known that idea i would
have been able to solve a problem that i
that i wasn't able to solve before
um and then i can
you know and and then i can see uh on
the other hand
um
since this is called the polyvlog or
polylog or something like that uh
there are there are things that
that are really
intellectually interesting
um but could never ever be useful
because they only
because it's an idea that only
whatever affect computations that are
much larger than the size of the
physical universe
and and and so it you know if you
so there are many yes interesting
questions about
how
computation
proceeds if if if the amount of data
becomes infinite
and these these these questions um
help us
to understand bottlenecks and and uh and
and the limitations on what we know
but there's been
i i think that has
gotten that part of the field has gotten
more developed than the other parts that
that are equally deserving um
which which are more
more down to earth with uh uh with
with things that are good that we can
use that we can use uh right sort of
tech
application real computers yeah
so is there anything you find
particularly worrisome about the
direction computer science is going or
well uh the most worrisome is that is
the emphasis on
getting paid for your ideas or something
i guess i i i i don't i i don't react
positively
to um
wall street trends
as
i
i i most
i i
i i tend to
i don't know i i tend to uh
uh
be be jealous of astronomers when
people say oh you're in astronomy
because
because you must really love to
understand things about the star
but but then you say oh you must be in
computer science because because you
want to be rich
and
and that is
you know way
invisible on my own list of
motivations now
and and and so um
i
i
so how do i
express his best i uh i don't know i
when i when i
left mathematics in the 60s and became a
computer scientist
i was i was beginning to be disenchanted
by the number of lectures i went to in
mathematics where i accept
back row and i said so what so what and
and i found that a lot of
a lot of the
directions that mathematically taken in
that way was only based on a problem
that had been suggested by a problem
that had been convicted by a problem
that had been subjected to something
else it was all
academic game playing
rather than
somehow
rich
well all the problems in computer
science were
were
both
academically interesting and
and rich
now i'm finding that
that i'm warming
much more to
the
things i read in mathematics journals
where they have returned to their roots
and they understand what you know
the importance of of
kind of problems that i like
and conversely
i've seen more computer science problems
that are
you know based on solving problems posed
by some problems with some problems
and and and entirely academic
and and and getting away from roots
again so
so any field i'm sure gets into this
in this situation and there's always
good and all these old
foggies like me will be calling for
uh return to the roots
um but you asked me anyway what i'm like
so so anyway i'm i'm very i'm very
pleased to continue uh
that some people still think i'm a
mathematician i mean to go in the other
direction could you say that euler was a
computer scientist i would say he was a
mathematician i i i think
that
of all the people who were great
computer scientists before computer
science was born you know you have to
plot some kind of a spectrum and say
well how close were they to being a geek
and
how i might define a geek and i would
say alan turing
was the closest he had the strongest uh
a pure
understanding of computation of uh and
his brain was was wired uh like
like a computer scientist more than
others was let's see
as i read um
you know i love to read source text
when when when
people discovered an idea i i like to
see how they described it in their own
words right rather than how it was
rehashed by somebody else and i can see
uh
with the help of
dictionary and translations and so on
i've been able to look at sanskrit texts
and and i can
i find people from the
you know from the 12th century
who were working on problems that i know
that i worked on as well and and i can
see what they were thinking you know and
i think i could sort of
feel that we're speaking to each other
across the centuries and that they
probably
their friends didn't have the slightest
idea what they were talking about they
would be fellow geeks
if the computers had existed then they
would have been computer scientists i'm
i'm sure there was one thing i was that
i have in my notes is that um
you said premature optimization is the
root of all evil
yeah well this was a this was a
a quote i think people even made up
made a button uh
on it and this meant that
um
you have to understand what optimization
means but from standpoint of of
computation
uh
we went out
we want our computer programs uh to use
the computer uh
well so so that if something
can be done in a day
uh you know it's better that than
if it takes a month
um
it's
not
much point in
arguing about
you know
speeding up something from
one minute to one second but
but uh
but
all through my life i've been involved
with things where i knew that this
particular part of the program was going
to be repeated a trillion times and so
if i could you know if i if i could save
100 nanoseconds i would be saving i
don't know
an hour maybe so so um
i
i uh
that that's called optimization is it is
when i have a process that works but i
want to make
but i want to make it better
um
on the other hand if i
if i'm thinking if if before i finish
the program if i'm trying to think about
making it better
then then i i i'm
almost always making a mistake because i
don't understand the program well enough
i don't know where the bottlenecks are i
don't
i i i'm using trickier ideas that are
more likely to be wrong
uh and until until like
until i get it wrong so
uh
so it
it's like um
you're a writer it's it's like you you
you're trying to write your last draft
like
you know before you get to chapter two
um yeah impossible very bad idea
it definitely has to be messy before it
can be clearing advice for me at least
iterate and improve on something
but not until it's time to approve it
okay well thank you very much it's been
lovely to talk to you as ever
okay
[Music]
you